book-smart is the directorial debut of
Olivia Wilde and tells the tale of two
seniors who are about to graduate who
have spent their entire high school
years intensely studying never missing a
project never missing homework always
trying their best to get into a great
college and when they discover that
other kids in school did party but are
somehow still getting into good colleges
they feel like they missed a huge
opportunity they have one more night
before graduation they decide to spend
that entire night finding the best party
they can in today's world of internet
ratings tomato meter Metacritic IMDB you
can really start to get expectations for
a movie that aren't necessary this is a
well-made comedy directed by somebody
who understands the genre especially for
a directorial debut and it has two
really good performances in it that
really boost the film and make it
something that's going to be impactful
for today's generation it's very
quotable it has a lot of funny scenes it
was hard to escape trailers for it
though because just about every film I
went to had a trailer for it and I don't
really like to know that much about
films I try to avoid as much as I can
going in so I can go into the film just
not knowing anything so that I can have
a fresh experience and hopefully be
surprised so it was nice to see a comedy
without all of the best jokes spoiled
for me
like most comedy trailers do the film
also has a really good sense of
immediacy because a large chunk of it
takes place over the course of one night
so you feel like you're really there
with these people it never feels like
it's really stopping or slowing down and
it's like this constant sequence of
events that continues to be entertaining
it actually builds an entertainment
value as the film goes along it doesn't
really peak necessarily at any one point
and by the end of the film I found
myself wrapped up in these characters
lives I actually cared about them I
wanted them to be in a happy place I
wanted to see them succeed and that's
when I knew the film had completely won
me over sometimes though the film can
feel a little fantastical as if
characters are in a scene improving
playing off a joke playing off the other
actor and you can sort of see this
improvisational sequence just played to
its extremes on film sometimes when
you're watching a movie especially
comedies you can feel when they're going
off script and riffing off one another
sometimes it's hilarious and sometimes
it were
for the character other times it feels
like they're going for a laugh and the
laugh just isn't coming there's a few
sequences like that in the movie that
don't always land for me but that's
subjective comedies gonna be that way
that's why it's so hard to direct
comedies which is why I have a lot of
respect for Olivia Wilde for going out
there and making this her directorial
debut and actually having a vision for
it because it does feel unique it does
have a unique look to it it feels as if
she brought something to this project
there's an energy to it there's a
vibrancy to it and a lot of that energy
is because of excellent performances by
Kaitlyn Dever and beanie Feldstein these
two girls play off each other
wonderfully they're supposed to have a
very deep friendship these two
characters right down to them knowing
some seriously fucked-up secrets about
the other person and you can feel that
on screen it felt completely authentic
their relationship was fleshed out even
though you didn't really know that much
about their past just in minimal
dialogue throughout their conversation
over the course of this night you can
begin to feel as if these characters
existed before the movie began and they
will continue to exist after it ends
which is one of the best compliments
that you can give to a film character is
that you feel like these people have
lives beyond the confines of the film
you're watching but one thing I
definitely noticed is that the film
relies very heavily on music whether
it's a song or musical score there is
rarely a scene that doesn't have one of
those sometimes that can get
overpowering it's relying a little too
heavily on music for that emotional
manipulation rather than script and
character especially in one sequence my
favorite scene in the entire film is
when two characters are having this
really big argument it's done in one
take the actors are doing an amazing job
it was actually really powerful and I
thought it was great work and then all
of a sudden during this sequence the
actors voices is drowned out from the
mix taken all the way down to zero and
musical score is suddenly over them and
they're arguing now and their mouths are
moving but no sounds coming out and we
just have this booming musical score and
to me that was a betrayal of these
amazing performances and again overly
relying on music when you didn't have to
have the music they're they're sequences
throughout the movie that really rely
early on very noticeable musical edits
sometimes you cut to an exterior shot of
a house music is super loud then we cut
to inside the house and all of a sudden
SRIA lis quiet the movie is trying to
jar you with its choices with music and
sometimes it works and sometimes I think
they should have just relied on these
two great actresses and what they were
already bringing to the movie beyond
that though I think this is a really fun
movie with two great performances and I
want to see what else Olivia Wilde does
because I think she has a lot of talent
go out and see this movie supported at
the box office it's a small film and I
want to see movies like this succeed I'm
gonna give book-smart a B guys thank you
so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]